this episode is made possible by
Skillshare home to over 16,000 classes
that could help you learn a new life
skill you don't believe that they've
gone to space new no no at all the
Rockets go up sure there's nobody in
them without a doubt in my mind I
believe vaccinations triggered Evans
autism so I think they need to wake up
and stop hurting our kids I don't like
putting chemicals in the water to turn
the friggin frogs gay do you understand
that Platt conspiracy theories are all
around us and in our modern world they
can spread and grow faster than ever
before
odds are you probably know at least one
person who buys into one of the many
theories polluting the Internet as
studies have shown that nearly 50% of
Americans believe at least one
conspiracy theory and if you believe in
one you are more likely to be
susceptible to others some of these
ideas are mostly harmless many people
just want to believe that their favorite
artist or actor is alive and well on
some remote island others are more
dangerous vaccines cause autism man-made
climate changes a hoax or the mainstream
media is all fake news as strange and
often ridiculous as these ideas seem
they capture hundreds of thousands of
people in an age where real facts and
evidence are easily accessible where do
these conspiracy theories come from over
the last two decades or so we've seen
some truly bizarre theories pop up and
gain loyal followings from the world
secretly being run by reptilian elite to
the resurgence of the long disproven
claim that the earth is flat to many
people these ideas seem absurd and are
dismissed without further thought but
there are plenty of people who actually
believe them so who are these people
for the most common conspiracy theories
the susceptible groups actually change
pretty predictably every time a new
president is elected the losing side has
to rationalize the defeat and more often
than not some radical claim surfaces to
explain away the loss or cast doubt on
its legitimacy as co-author of American
conspiracy theories Joseph Kosinski
writes conspiracy theories are for
losers and he doesn't mean that
insulting Lee but rather literally he
goes on to say people who have lost an
election money or influence look for
something to explain that loss when
Barack Obama was running for president
and even long after he was elected
conspiracy theorist claimed that he
wasn't actually
US citizen and was therefore ineligible
for the office Obama tried to put an end
to the rumors by releasing his short
form birth certificate at which point
they demanded the long-form and when he
provided that the conspiracy theorists
insisted it was a forgery this is what
separates the sore losers from the true
conspiracy theorists when presented with
evidence against their position they
interpret it as the opposite evidence of
a larger conspiracy to suppress the
truth but what is it that makes some
people so much more susceptible than
others studies have shown that generally
speaking belief in conspiracy theories
is inversely related to wealth and
education one survey showed that about
42% of people without a high school
education believe in at least one
conspiracy theory compared to 23% of
people with a postgraduate degree a more
recent study from 2017 found a household
income of just over $47,000 among people
who were inclined to believe in
conspiracy theories and just under
64,000 dollars among those who weren't
Joseph's parent you since Keyes
co-author and professor of political
science at Notre Dame says conspiracy
theories can be like emotional poultice
'as you don't want to blame yourself for
things you may lack so you blame
anonymous forces instead but education
and income aren't the only factors in
priming individuals for belief in
conspiracy theories in one study from
May of 2017 researchers determined that
people who feel a strong desire to be
special or stand out from the crowd are
overwhelmingly more likely to believe in
any number of conspiracy theories
interestingly as much as these people
want to stand out from the crowd
group affiliation is also incredibly
important conspiracy theorists rally
behind social media groups and hashtags
often taking pride in the nickname
society comes up with for them people
opposed to vaccinating their children
out of the misguided belief that
vaccines cause autism will tag their
long Facebook rants with hashtag
anti-vaxxer and this is where conspiracy
theorists cross the line from social
misfit to outright public danger in 2017
there were 58 confirmed cases of measles
in Minnesota the largest outbreak the
state had seen in 30 years nine years
earlier in 2008 a large outbreak in
California was traced back to a
seven-year-old boy who had not been
vaccinated less than a decade before
measles had been all but totally
eliminated in the United States the
dangerous thing about people like
anti-vaxxers is that they're completely
unwilling to budge on their opinion even
in the face
of overwhelming evidence a simple Google
search will return hundreds of scholarly
articles and studies on the efficacy and
safety of vaccines but it doesn't matter
climate change deniers are another group
willfully ignorant of reality when
presented with decades of scientific
evidence these individuals will claim
that it's a global conspiracy and that
the entirety of the scientific community
is in on it
twisting the evidence to fit some
unknown agenda as frustrating as
conversations with conspiracy theorists
can be evolutionarily speaking the
existence of conspiracy theories makes
sense to some extent we are all pre
disposed to be mistrustful of other
groups and especially those in power our
ancestors survived by being cautious
around other groups for their own safety
of course that does not excuse
conspiracy theorists for peddling
ridiculous and inflammatory ideas such
as the claim that the Holocaust never
happened
plenty of people function just fine in
modern society without subscribing to
absurd fantasies besides the need to
feel special and usually a lack of
higher education some studies have
suggested a tendency towards narcissism
is highly correlated to belief in
conspiracy theories the idea that they
can be privy to some secret information
that even relevant experts can't or
refuse to understand so what we end up
with is a person who rapidly believes
their right is unwilling to change their
position uses contrary facts as evidence
of a larger conspiracy and treats their
chosen conspiracy like team sports
if conspiracy theorists can't be swayed
by evidence what can we do to help end
some of the more damaging ideas one
strategy that's already in place is
helping people to determine trustworthy
sources of information there are several
websites designed to fact-check and help
curb the spread of misinformation but
it's not enough when someone finds an
article or video that reaffirms their
position on a topic they're not likely
to check if it's a reliable source
another more useful method is simply to
have conversations with friends or
family who believe in a conspiracy
theory not to ridicule them or throw
scholarly articles in their face but
just to understand where they're coming
from asking questions can go a long way
in helping you and your conversation
partner understand why they hold the
opinions they do one tool that is
particularly useful in dealing with
conspiracy theories is Occam's razor the
idea that the simplest explanation is
usually the most accurate take the Flat
Earth conspiracy for example what's more
likely that thousands of photographs
videos scientific studies mathematician
physicists geologists pilots astronauts
the most brilliant thinkers in history
and the entire scientific community as a
whole are wrong or in on a massive
cover-up to hide the fact that the earth
is actually flat or that the earth is in
fact a globe like it appears to be of
course you can't go out and expect a
reason conspiracy theorists into
changing their views but you can help by
providing good trustworthy sources to
those who ask for them and by teaching
your peers and younger people how to
think critically and evaluate sources of
information our ability to learn is one
of the greatest skills we have which is
why I will always recommend Skillshare
to anyone looking to learn something new
or improve on an existing skill
Skillshare is home to thousands of
classes in animation photography video
game design music web development and
more these days you can learn just about
anything online and Skillshare is an
amazing way to do it a premium
membership from Skillshare is more
affordable than most other online
learning platforms and gives you
unlimited access to amazing classes from
experts working in their fields so you
can improve your skills unlock new
opportunities and do the work you love
as a special offer for fans of second
thought you can get your first two
months for just 99 cents when you sign
up using the link below why not start
right now and learn that new skill
you've always wanted to support second
thought and learn valuable new skills
sign up for Skillshare using the link
below if you enjoyed this video consider
subscribing to support the channel and
click that little bell to make sure
you're actually notified every time a
new second thought video is uploaded if
you're not sure what to watch next
check out these playlists full of other
great content thanks for watching and
we'll see you next week